good morning believe nation today's
messages do what you love right Toby
right do what you love yeah over to you
Sean Combs I loved what I was doing I
decided what I was gonna do a job I
loved what I was doing I would walk
around I would dance and sing as I was
delivering my papers and that kind of
helped me to for the future of what I
wanted to do and now with just being a
young entrepreneur I thank God every day
that I'm blessed with the chance to to
do something that I love doing but I
feel anybody could do something that
that they love doing if they if they go
after it in the right way if they go
after with the love the motivation for
it is the love and the love of leaving a
legacy behind more than the selfishness
of just doing it for money doing it to
blow up to beat a man at a woman but I
have the fame if you do it to make
history if you do it to change people's
lives to make people feel good to make
yourself feel good it's gonna come it's
just gonna come naturally do it to make
history do it to change lives I loved
that part of his message because too
many people start a business just trying
to make money and yes it's important to
make money right you have to pay your
bills and put food on the table have an
internet connection all of that is super
important but what's really gonna
motivate you what's really going to get
you excited is feeling like the work
that you're doing is important has the
ability to make history and have an
impact on people's lives when you touch
somebody and when you know that what you
have done is important to them and it's
improved their lives somehow man that is
one of the greatest feelings in the
world that's a drug that's a drug that
you want to repeat and do it again and
again and again and that's why I keep
doing these YouTube videos because
seeing you guys and your feedback in
your comments and knowing that it's
having an impact in your life makes me
so happy and proud and confident
and I want to go and do it some more so
don't just focus on doing something that
you think you would make a lot of money
with do something that you love and pour
that energy into trying to make history
and improve people's lives this also
applies to everything in your life this
isn't just a business principle if you
want to have a happy marriage you know
you have to love your husband or wife if
you want to have a great relationship
with your kids and be a good father or
mother you have to love your kids you
want to bring energy and enthusiasm and
excitement and love right mr. right into
everything you do that's your recipe for
success of being a happy person to
having a great business and having an
impact and making the world a better
place making your dreams turn from a
dream into actually being reality so
love what you do make history improve
people's lives and make that decision
powerfully believe so my question today
today is what do you love most about
what you do in your business leave in
the comments below I'm curious to see
what it is for you thank you so much for
watching continue to believe have an
amazing day and I'll see you again
tomorrow morning for another shot of
vinspresso good morning believe nation
hey Toby come back hey sit sit sit come
here okay good boy stay there okay okay
okay ready you ready for your cameo on
YouTube as soon as I say hi you've run
off huh okay get ready stay there stay
stay